[Musique]
je m'appelle victor lesage et g11
je suis enfant unique et j'adore la
lecture tous les sports le passionne
mais plus particulièrement la crosse et
le football d'ailleurs je fais partie de
l'équipe de l'école du scorpion les
différences dans notre société me parles
tu lt métier de plus en plus accord avec
le tas
je vois cela soude un autre
tout comme moi j'espère qu'après la
présentation vous allez voir le monde
donnait sur fermez vos yeux et imaginez
que vous êtes téléporter comme ceux ci
aux états unis mais que vous ne parlait
pas très bien anglais
vous allez avoir peur et c'est normal
après deux semaines vous allez commencer
à vous être adaptée imaginez maintenant
que vous êtes téléporter en arabie
saoudite labo les styles vestimentaires
différents la langue différente et la
religion est différent bref tout est
différent
ça vaut pour prendre deux semaines nous
adapter mais plutôt deux mois qu'est ce
que je veux dire 15 10 e s'il faut juste
se donner le temps de s'adapter parce
qu'on appose qu'on connaît pas on ne vit
pas d'amour tort je vous donne un
exemple admettons que moi je vais le
groupe religieux et que mon voisin vient
d'un autre groupe religieux voulons pas
d'amour tort par rapport à mes croyances
et à celle de mon voisin on aussi par la
différence ethnique mais c'est quoi une
ethnie selon le dictionnaire antidote
ardoise une ethnie c'est un regroupement
de personnes unifié par une même langue
elle-même culture et qui possède une
structure familiale économique et social
homogène mais on détermine plus souvent
une ethnie par les styles vestimentaires
la langue la couleur de peau et la
religion en parlant de religion pour
plusieurs personnes qu'en dit le mot
ethnie
le premier mot qui sont dans leur tête
c'est religion dans le jeu j'ai pensé
vous dire quelles étaient les cinq
régions les plus pratiquées au mans en
premier et le christianisme avec 30% de
la population mondiale ce qui représente
2 3 millions d'adeptes ensuite l'islam
vrai pour sa 1,4 milliard l'hindouisme
avec est ce pour ça soit 812 millions le
bouddhisme caisse pour ça 325 millions
et le judaïsme avec 0,4 pour ça c'est
qu'il représente 12 millions d'adeptes
mais le christianisme n'est pas
nécessairement une mère religion à cause
qu'il ya plus d'adeptes non parce que si
cinq régions sont monothéistes ce qu'il
veut dire qu'ils ont un dieu unique et
tous les religions monothéistes du monde
ont les mêmes valeurs le respect et
l'amour on aurait davantage à s'inspirer
de ce qui promet ici le respect et
l'amour parce qu'il faudra prouver que
quand on en banque
cela peut mener à des conflits majeurs
je vais vous donner des exemples
premièrement pendant la guerre de
sécession qui opposait le nom des états
unis au sud à cause que l'on voulait
abolir l'esclavagé
si tu veux dire l'arrêter et le sud ne
voulait tout simplement pas tout cela à
cause compte qu'on sert pas les noirs
comme égal ou blanc le deuxième exemple
c'est pas un deuxième guerre mondiale
quand hitler a fait le génocide des
juifs à costil disait qu'il ruine et
l'économie allemand ce kit est
complètement vous et c'était encore une
fois à cause qu'il ne considérait pas
les noirs les juifs comme égal à sa race
soit on peut imaginer maintenant qu'il
faut changer le code pour jour au
lendemain est-ce que vous allez penser
la même chose vous habille la même façon
peut-être que oui peut-être que non mais
c'est pas la couleur de peau la langue
la religion ou la bill mcinnis quelqu'un
si ses pensées ses idées mais surtout
surtout ses actes alors la prochaine
fois que vous allez faire face à la
différence est détournée par le record
mais regardez là plutôt en france merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]